pas plus
pourquoi je retourne chez nathan je
crois que je retourne chez nathan parce
que je me sens comme un poisson dans
l'eau
et lui en attente sait on encore rien
je connais tout le monde et tout le
monde connaît j'ai fait l'amitié de
gardes du corps je protège les gens les
commerçants des hommes d'affaires et
aussi des hommes politiques les acteurs
des chanteurs existera mais ici et y en
a tant
ce n'est pas pareil c'est chez moi
souvent je traîne dans tous les
restaurants bars de nuit je ne peux pas
passer en force et ma boule dessous on
sait que je suis garde du corps et s'il
ya des problèmes
malheureusement parfois ça arrive même
bénévolement
j'interdis com
à sa mort il faut lancer un temps je
suis en quelque sorte d'un kamikaze
voilà deux de ce métier c'est ça qui en
fait le prix pour vous alors oui je suis
en ce moment
qu'est ce qu'ils font comme qualités
pour pouvoir faire ce métier d'abord une
bonne santé j'aime entraînement physique
[Applaudissements]
et
et ce tour là les qualités a pas pu être
humain il faut aimer la personne que
vous protéger mais à mort au cas où on
peut même aller jusqu'à la mort la peine
vous protège
[Musique]
un jour je lui ai parlé à paris j'étais
dans le métro et les trois garçons
qu'elle a qu'une femme est large et en
allemand j'interviens réactualisées tous
les trois après j'ai accompagné la
surveillance c'est vrai c'est ce qui m'a
déclenché l envie de faire ce métier de
garde du pont
[Musique]
un gars comme hadopi
j'ai beaucoup souffert déjà quand je
suis venu en bateau pendant les boat
people quand on le sait déjà c'est à toi
10% de man il fallait survivre les flets
bois s'ébattaient d'avoir beaucoup
d'énergie j'ai utilisé cette énergie là
pour travailler pour protéger des gens
c'est à dire la protection la protection
rapprochée
comment vous avez vu le goût des
inventions
je loue un journal on a mal on voit un
film comme la plupart des gosses d'un
film de mousseline et depuis ce jour là
ça a déclenché en main les français se
font plein d idées
c'est le 7e temps afin de composer le
voir mais travaille travaille sept jours
succès un style pour vous manger tout
seul
dimanche à 5 et se partagent tout
l'appartement nous habite à plusieurs
c'est partage de voiture ils
s'entraident pour monter les commerçants
frein
[Musique]
ils vous disent ma porte cette force de
rester calme même quand il ya le feu
des gens qui sont formes d'arts martiaux
ne se bas jamais quand je protège
quelqu'un
le plus difficile ce n'est pas ça va
éviter de ses bases c'est pour ça que je
viens très souvent mavs au qg à 7 ans
et
les inventions et le bouddhisme ça va
bien ensemble oui pourquoi pas ce que ça
représente au leader des choses la
sagesse
et vous voulez mais un fait
guillaume nadeau piano
quand j'ai quitté ma vie d'homme sur le
bateau j'avais 14 ans je suis resté sept
jours sans manger une loi il ya eu les
attaques des pirates allant d'un je me
suis battu et mais que j'ai été blessé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de mouvement et de réussir
[Musique]
es tu